hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream it's been a while since we did
one but we're back and we have an
amazing guest wendy kopp ceo of teach
for all also the founder of teach for
america we're going to talk about her
journey and all of her learnings about
education and where we might be going
but before we do that i will give my
standard announcements first a reminder
that we are not for profit here at khan
academy so if you're in a position to do
so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate i'm making a donation of any size
it really does make a difference and it
was it's what allows uh allows us to
serve millions tens of millions of
students around the world
uh the next uh thing i'd like to make
sure we recognize many folks who have
stepped up
especially when the pandemic hit
and more folks than ever were dependent
upon khan academy special thanks to bank
for america at t google.org novartis
fastly and general motors for really
stepping up and as we all know
unfortunately we're still in this
pseudo-pandemic mode but even
post-pandemic this is where
khan academy might be even more
important to make sure that we can get
everyone back up to speed and have a
strong foundation having everyone learn
at their own pace
last but not least there is a version of
this live stream in podcast form
wherever you get your podcasts homeroom
with sal the podcast
with that out of the way
i'm so excited to introduce wendy kopp
who i consider a good friend and someone
who i generally look up to in in all
things in my life
including including founding uh
organizations and all the rest wendy
welcome
thank you so good to be here looking
forward
so maybe a good and i'll remind everyone
who's watching on facebook or youtube
any questions you have for wendy about
her journey or about education generally
put them in the message boards we'll be
able to look at those questions and i'll
try to surface as many as i can
during our conversation but wendy maybe
a good place to start
i think a lot of maybe a lot of folks
have heard for teach for all maybe not
everyone has a lot of folks might have
heard for teach for america some might
not have what is teach for all and what
is teach for america
so um
i'll start with teach for all teach for
all started
just about 14 years ago
um and it was i mean i had my head down
and i'll get back to this in a minute
just working to grow the impact of teach
for america which i had started maybe 30
plus years ago um and i wasn't thinking
at all about the rest of the world but
there was just something in the water
and i started meeting
amazing people social entrepreneurs from
all over the world who were interested
in seeing something similar happen in
their countries
and so and one they were looking for
support and help and that led to the
launch of teach for all is a network of
independent locally led organizations
now in 60 countries around the world
that all share a common purpose which is
to develop collective leadership to
ensure all kids fulfill their potential
and we all share a common approach for
doing that um
which is really
kind of the approach that that we
pioneered initially at teach for america
of you know enlisting promising leaders
people of all different academic
backgrounds and career interests in
committing at least two years to teach
in under-resourced communities investing
in their leadership supporting them as
they commit really their lives to
working as leaders and advocates for the
systemic changes necessary to create a
fair
and and equitable and excellent
education system
now there's so much in there i i hope to
unpack
well let's go to the you know you just
explained a little bit about how teach
for all came to be and its theory of
action
and it really did to some degree emerge
out of the work that you've been doing
for for many decades at teach for
america tell us a little bit about that
journey because you were quite young uh
when you started and i know there's a
lot of young people listening who who
for the most part everyone wants to find
purpose in their life everyone wants to
know how do i provide for my family but
even more important potentially make a
dent in the universe make make a
difference
how did you find your purpose through
teach for america and then teach for all
it's so interesting sal because this
started when i was a college senior
and i was in a funk for the first time
in my life really i mean i had been
completely driven taking on one issue or
another
and then i got to my senior year and i
realized i have to figure out what i'm
going to do for the rest of my life and
you know our generation was called the
me generation supposedly we all just
wanted to go out and work for banks and
management consulting firms
and i just i didn't want to do that and
i just found myself just searching for a
way to assume a big responsibility and
make a real difference in the world and
i got this sense that i wasn't alone
that there were thousands of other
people out there searching for exactly
the same thing and as i went through all
of that i'd also become just a very
concerned college student focused on
you know the inequities in our country
and particularly on the issues in
education the fact that where kids are
born does so much to predict educational
outcomes and life outcomes and and one
day all that just came together and i
thought why aren't we being recruited as
aggressively to commit just two years to
teach
in urban and rural public schools in our
country as we were being recruited to
commit just two years to work on wall
street and i just became completely
obsessed with this idea i thought it was
going to change the country you know
like
it was going to channel all this energy
into classrooms which was going to be
really important for kids growing up
today but i also thought how different
would the country be if we took all
these quote promising leaders and had
their first two years out of college be
teaching in low-income communities
instead of working at banks i thought
that would change our priorities our
consciousness as a country so
that was the big idea i needed a thesis
topic it was an idea that was very
quickly far beyond me
um
yeah that's the beginning of it at least
well i think to some degree it has
changed america
i think many of those people might have
gone into uh banking or something not
that there's anything wrong with that
too there's many people who do very
powerful things and very important
things uh after that uh but i do think
you know the number of people i know who
are teach for america alumni who know
something about education who care about
the issue and some of them stayed in
education some of them have gone into
other professions
but i think it has changed them and it
has changed
how they lead it has changed how they
the other organizations that they now
lead think about education
but i want to go back to that moment
because
i too as a senior and i think senior
year i was probably we were probably
similar in certain ways
i i felt like i had all this energy i
felt like i had all of the stuff for the
world i was like where do i get the the
maximum impact on the world and i did
also sometimes have big dreams but then
i was like well how do i make that
happen so what did you do that allowed
you to take that pretty bold vision
and turn it into actual action that
eventually did
get pretty close or even better than
that bold vision because eventually you
went global that wasn't even part of
your original vision yeah um so i think
i had a gift in that i had a thesis
requirement i mean you know i had to
write an undergraduate thesis and i was
also really searching for a topic and i
decided this would be the topic
and that really forced me to
think a lot about this i mean i
researched the policy context the
previous
models on which that we could learn from
like the peace corps or there was a
federal teacher actually in the 60s or
vista
in the u.s um
i looked at the mood on college campuses
and and honestly i spent a lot of the
thesis research looking for this i was
just the more i got into it the more it
just was so clear the timing was perfect
and
this must be happening i was looking
who's doing this like because at the
time first of all there were huge
teacher shortages i mean huge headlines
like 1200 teachers short in new york
thousand teachers short in la um there
was also a real interest in the country
for the first like fortune magazine
cover stories on how
corporate america was going to take on
education
um and i just thought
yeah anyway that became how i did it
honestly like i ended up became coming i
realized no one's doing it and the time
is going to pass like someone has to do
it and so i developed a four-page plan
saying this is how we're going to do it
and
turn in the thesis boil it down into 30
pages and i sent it to all those
executives quoted in that magazine
article
um and i you know there was no email i
was mailing letters calling following up
and i got a few meetings off of that
those letters and
again
it was one of those ideas that was
capturing people i got a seat grant i
spent my summer just
trying to meet anyone who would meet me
with of course i had no credibility i
mean that
i would send 100 letters and get a
meeting or two but as i tell everyone
you can get 98 no's or 99 if you get one
person saying yes and that sort of
became how like ultimately
we gained a little traction but honestly
i mean one more thing to share
everywhere i went i mean i was getting
into superintendents and
potential donors and various people
again i would meet one person and they
would lead me to others
everywhere i went people said this is a
great idea it will never work and the
reason they thought it wouldn't work is
they thought the college students would
never do it i had a list of 100 campuses
public and private historically black
colleges and ivy league schools and
people looked at the list and said
you'll never get kids from these schools
to want to teach in low-income
communities and that was the one thing i
had a reason to have conviction about
and so that became the plan we're going
to show people
so
we i you know people were walking
through the door other recent grads i
mean we launched a grassroots
recruitment campaign flyers under doors
again no email um and you know we had
2500 people apply within within three or
four months that generated media
what what when was that after i
yeah
i mean one year after i graduated it all
come together we had 500 people in an
auditorium embarking on a summer
training institute we had experienced
teachers from all over the country in
urban and rural areas come together to
be trainers for them
we had school systems in six places
agree to hire them and somehow we raised
two and a half million dollars to fund
it anyway that was the first year but i
always tell people that's when the
learning curve began because these folks
started teaching and we realized how
hard this would be and
that's what's kept me in it you know
just the incredible learning curve and
learning journey about
how to actually do this well like how to
recruit and select people who are ready
for this and train and support them to
succeed with their kids to learn the
right lessons to ultimately fulfill
their potential as a force for the
systemic changes that we need um
yeah
and i want to get into that in a second
but i also want to make sure we don't
glaze over some things that i think you
just glazed over
that
you have this thesis and that does seem
like a powerful forcing function to
doing your research thinking through the
plan etc etc
but but then i'm really fascinated about
that moment from idea to actually
starting to get a little bit of traction
so you were literally took copies of
essentially your of your thesis or
version of your thesis you put them in
like manila envelopes figured out
somehow the the mailing address like you
just say like you know big corporation x
which you could find the address and you
just put the name of the ceo on top and
and hoping and it did actually work
okay so i had a mix of people i
took the names in the article quoted
about how we needed like the head of the
business roundtable at the time or the
next person and yeah i looked up their
addresses and mailed them letters and
then i would call and follow up
and i also added some other ceos from
random companies out of like the book of
big corporations i mean it honestly i
had the advantage of naivete um
and i had been
i mean so so i got seven meetings off
those letters that that's one thing to
note i said
i got seven meetings not necessarily
with the ceos by the way but whoever
they handed them down to and one of
those meetings
someone said you can use our office in
manhattan
so i got some office space and the other
said
it was just taken with the idea and
it's a long story but he said if you can
get princeton to be the conduit of funds
i'll make the seed grant and
i had met the princeton development
director because my thesis advisor had
insisted on it this man was going to
explain to me how impossible this was
going to be
and i called that man and he was like i
cannot believe you got a grant and he he
made it happen so anyway and this i'm
just here how much was the seed grant
twenty six thousand dollars i mean this
twenty six thousand dollars
i said i'll come up with a budget these
were my expenses for the summer in
today's money that might be 40 000 but
but not like an enormous amount of money
but this was enough money was this you
know you was it like you could start
taking a salary to start flushing it out
more you could start what other other
costs you might do today i don't even
know if i had a salary but i had no
money so i needed to live so it was like
expenses for a summer of like exploring
whether this could work that that was
how i framed the whole thing and then
how did you go from that and i do want
to go into all of the learning over the
last especially well recent times but
especially over the last three decades
but how did you go from that to a year
later having 500 people in a room and
having all of these
it's one thing to get a 26 000 grant
it's another thing
to
actually even though they were skeptical
in hindsight it feels like the student
part might have been the easier part but
getting the districts to say yes we will
place these teachers having enough money
to do the training for all of these
folks um being able to do it in a
responsible way so that you're going to
put them in classrooms they're going to
be teaching kids et cetera et cetera
like
was it just a series of small steps yeah
i mean it was all in the four-page plan
but yes um i will say
i mean i think every piece of this work
is is a challenge right like
i think actually one of the hardest
things we do still to this day
is inspire people with a lot of other
options to say i want to do this and
so but it is true that that there's a
certain group of people out there i
think in that first year we magnetized
the people who saw this and was you know
i want to be part of that and i think as
we work to to grow beyond that core
group
it became all the more challenging to
figure out how to do it um
you know the school district part was
not the hard part i i still remember
these initial meetings i had with urban
district superintendents and heads of
human resources like one very memorable
meeting with the head of human resources
in the los angeles school district the
guy started laughing he was looking at
my list of 100 colleges and he just
laughed and said i'll tell you what
you get students from these colleges to
want to teach in my schools and i will
hire all 500 of them and that was kind
of the reaction i was getting because
there really there was just there was
such a need for teachers and there was
in many ways it was a very different
world 30 years ago i mean we've seen
school districts in the us become so
much more sophisticated in how they're
recruiting
teachers i mean it used to be a very
different world um
figuring out how to train them i found
my way to really progressive teacher
educators and
i knew we knew nothing so i mean we kind
of subcontracted with them
um and said please design a training
institute you know and there was a lot i
mean you know we were working 24 7.
there was a team of people of course
like
a bunch of other recent graduates some
who had taught some who had done the
peace corps others who were straight out
of college and were inspired by this
mission but we put together
an amazing team of people young people
who just
made it happen through a lot of
all-nighters and
you know
campaign
yeah i think i think young people who
are watching this
i'm sure they are likely impressed
because it's not common that you'll see
a college senior or someone who's 21 or
22 years old be able to do this level
but we've had the last 20 or 30 years of
seeing examples of especially in the
for-profit sector of startups being
founded by college students and getting
off the ground but when you started this
this was not a normal thing it was not
normal for someone in their early 20s to
be able to start an entity of substance
uh but anyway i know we're short of time
but there there must have been something
really uh powerful about how you were
presenting yourself uh or maybe you just
had the right sponsors the right
advocates or combination uh that that
allowed you to get off the ground
because i would argue it's even harder
to start
a not-for-profit of meaning
relative to even a for-profit
i was obsessed with this idea and and i
think
that
was the thing um honestly more than
anything else and and
it was an idea that magnetized people
immediately i mean
and it really has since then right and
now it's doing that globally and
there was a lot that that's really what
it came down to was much less than
i don't know that i would have i wasn't
trying to think of something to start i
mean that was like the last thing i was
not in that mode at all it was just i
became so obsessed with this and i think
that's what made it work
and now
fast forward to today
what are your big takeaways you had some
hypotheses 30 years ago or whatever it
was
which of those
came true or maybe are even better than
what you expected which of those the
jury's still out and which of those are
you like well i'm not sure if that was
right but there's this other thing we
learned
so what's interesting about this i mean
as i shared earlier
part of what i was so obsessed about was
the long-term impact i thought this
would have like i thought it would
really reshape the priorities of a
generation
and i think i probably didn't understand
exactly how that piece was going to play
out but i think that piece has happened
in in spades um
you know and now there's all this
research and growing amounts of it that
look at what happens to these people
during the two years and we can look at
it not only in the us but now in other
countries as well
and what's fascinating is that these
effects
are so similar even from country to
country um like people
through those two years like they come
in i mean they go through this very
rigorous selection process and they come
in you know these studies look at people
who are right on the admissions line
some didn't get in and some did and then
it looks at what happens to their
mindsets and beliefs and understandings
two years later and beyond that um and
so they come in you know this election
model works we select people who believe
in kids and and families and low-income
communities but that conviction deepens
like the gap in their like level of
belief in the potential of kids and
families grows like meaning like they
believe more in their kids at the end
they also completely shift their
understanding of the nature of the
problem and the solutions like they come
in thinking all around the world like
the answer is technical you know it's
funding number one and number of
technical solutions and they come out
thinking this is a big systemic
problem that's going to take a lot of
adaptive change and a lot of leadership
from a lot of places
so they basically come out having a
bigger sense of possibility
knowing that no one silver bullet is
going to do it like the answer is is
much more complex
and they become all the more committed
to the work um you know they change
their career trajectories they never
leave the work essentially i mean you
look at the 70 000 some teach for
america alums and 86 percent of them are
full-time in the work like some of them
in education some of the others taking
on the other
aspects of the issues in low-income
communities and we're seeing the same
thing globally 75 of these
alumni all over the world are still
full-time in education so that part like
the idea that this was going to shape
these people and that it would end up
being not only about two years but about
every year after the two years like that
we got completely right
i don't know if i could have known
how that would play itself out over time
you know i think
you know it's probably made a bigger
impact in the long run in my biased
opinion then
then i could have predicted because of
the nature of the problem and and the
solution which we could talk about
and and i'll go to a second but how do
you think it's affected the education
environment
what's that alternative reality where
instead young wendy kopp went and got a
job as a management consultant and just
start teaching america what would the
world look like there
so this is where i was gonna go so i
think what i've learned over time and
what all of these people who get into
this work learn and what i'm sure you've
learned is that this really is a big
complex problem like there is no one
thing that's going to solve this problem
like more great teachers a different
curriculum a laptop for every kid a
charter school a different government i
mean there's no one thing it's going to
take
so many different things like it really
is just a very complex problem it's not
even all about schools and school
systems it's about
you know it's just a it's about the fact
that whole segments of kids face many
extra challenges that more privileged
kids don't face discrimination poverty
lack of access to adequate health care
and so many other things and then they
show up at schools never set up to meet
their extra needs and there's this kind
of prevailing ideology about the
potential of these marginalized
kids and so to solve that is going to
take collective leadership you know it's
going to take
a lot of people working together it's
going to take
teachers and school leaders and school
system leaders it's going to take the
social entrepreneurs figuring out how to
change the system it's going to take
policy leaders it's going to take
students and parents and advocates you
know we need a whole ecosystem of people
exerting leadership and
so i think what teach for
all network organizations have done is
contributed to that collective
leadership like they're enlisting people
you know from very diverse backgrounds
some who have
lived these inequities that we're
addressing and others from much more
privileged backgrounds so diverse group
of folks they're immersing them in this
experience and those people come out
believing we can solve this problem
understanding the nature of the problem
and taking it on alongside and in
partnership with many others
you know the systemic issues and
so i think what's changed like you can
see now i mean in the us you can see
communities where teach for america has
been placing a steady stream of people
for 30 years
um and i know it doesn't seem like it
because we still have massive inequities
and we're far from where we want to be
as a country in education
but if you actually looked at where
things were 30 years ago in these
communities versus where they are now in
terms of the state of education the
educational outcomes we've moved the
needle in a big way and not of course
just because of teach for america but if
you took all those teach for america
people
out of those communities you would take
a lot of the energy and leadership and
entrepreneurship that has fueled and
catalyzed and
and in some cases really driven the
change um and we're seeing just the same
effects all around the world it's almost
like seeing the same movie playing
in different countries
yeah and i'll add to that i'm sure it's
had impact on those communities but just
even on my own journey at khan academy
over the last
11 12 13 i guess it's been 16 years 17
years since i started tutoring family
but while i was doing this for real the
number of teach for america folks that
i've seen leading various work we've had
multiple teach for america folks at
various stages in khan academy all the
way to the early days who did some of
our school partnership work
the number of other not-for-profits or
for-profit but education ed tech
whatever you want to call it reform
your alumni are everywhere they are
driving these things so i do think
there's a direct impact on those
communities there's the ways that it has
changed these people directly and their
understanding of the system but it's
also these many of your folks have gone
out there and then have become mini
wendy's and and have started other parts
as to your point it's a
multi-dimensional approach there's many
vectors here
but going into the teaching itself you
know there's a bunch of questions that
are coming in from youtube raymond
cronin says how do you get students on
board with core classes they're not
interested in um there's another
question can you describe the progress
and education you've seen made uh and
and so
taking all that into account you know
what have you found make someone a
successful teacher and as to raymond's
question it's not just delivery of
content it is motivation of content it's
other things
what's what's your takeaways here how do
you see that talent and how do you
develop it
so first of all on the teaching question
and then let's come back to that second
question because that's a slightly
different one but
um we've learned so much and it's an
ongoing learning journey i think you
know my biggest thought in listening to
that question and just thinking about
what we've learned is that
you know i guess i've rethought what
we're even working towards you know when
we started out in this um
i mean all of course and still i mean
we're so driven by equity across the
teach for all network and and working
with the most marginalized kids i think
when i started my teach for american
journey i was thinking that meant
catching kids up to where more
privileged kids are
and
progressively we just realized how
insufficient that is like we're catching
kids up in a very broken system when
what we should be doing is enabling kids
and developing them
to exert the leadership to solve the
inequities to shape a better future for
themselves like navigate a changing
economy and for all of us like solve
these pressing problems that face our
society um
so it's interesting like we did a whole
set of studies
back in the day about what
differentiated teachers who produced the
biggest gains in student achievement you
know standardized test scores but we've
redone all those studies now looking at
what is it that differentiates the
teachers who are fostering students
agency their awareness in the world
their problem-solving skills their their
leadership you know including their you
know ability to apply the academic
knowledge to be strong critical thinkers
and strong problem solvers and all um
and
so
i guess what's come out of those studies
is the idea that the strongest teachers
first of all are so purpose driven like
they
are very clear on their ultimate aim
um
they build really strong relationships
with their students and
the students families and other teachers
in in the school um
and and then they're just they're
they're making choices that that foster
student agency and awareness and
well-being and and mastery um
i'm gonna pause i mean there are so many
there's so much to be said on this topic
but and what's your sense about
you know when you're fi when you're
looking
when you're looking at these young
people going into the teach for america
or the teach for all force
is there any way to to to find that
signal early on or do they just have to
learn as they go and then how do people
change with time and experience because
i've definitely heard the argument both
ways these are incredibly high potential
folks but then you might have senior
teachers who might not have quite you
know the same
background but they've learned things
over the years how do you see that
develop over time
yeah
um
i mean every teacher's journey is of
course a little bit different um
and and one thing i would just say i
mean we are trying to on the teaching
side be one more source of
you know deeply committed teachers
working alongside many other teachers
and
allies and parents and others trying to
help kids you know meet their extra
needs you know support them to live into
their full potential and it's a journey
it's a learning journey for any new
teacher including the those who we we
place and support um
i'm losing track of your
how do you question but
evolves over time like what what how do
you see the the the
even in the two years how do you see
your teachers change between year one
and year two what are they doing
differently
yeah you know it's so interesting
because
i just talked to a first-year teacher in
colombia
who
is working with a hundred students
across grades five through ten and he's
teaching math and physics and
he's never met the kids because he's
only taught in the pandemic
um
and he somehow started by teaching the
kids about the un's sustainable
development goals and then he got them
all involved in researching the reality
in rural columbia and then they became
very concerned about the water shortage
and the gas shortage
and these kids have developed solutions
to those problems
and he's literally hooked them up with
professors who are like please walk me
through the 3d
thing that you've like
so
he's a first-year teacher and and he
immediately just oriented towards
how do we foster students leadership
like let's do it today because there are
lots of problems in the world today and
he i mean he said a fifth grade girl is
leading the team he then entered them
into these different competitions and
they've done very well and he has the
fifth grade girl leading a team i mean
so
it's hard you know and then there are
other first-year teachers who come in
through our organization who
you know are completely overwhelmed and
who if they persist you know by the end
of the year wake up and realize they did
make a difference and then reflect over
the summer and come in
hitting the ground running the second
year i mean i i don't want to say
there's one journey but
um
yeah it's it's and we're selecting a
group of people
who one
want to be in this work who are deeply
driven to address these inequities
who want to be in the arena want you
know have high expectations for kids and
families and we're looking we're looking
for various things but including
a lot of evidence that they take on big
things and persevere in the face of
challenges because that's a huge part of
this um
we're looking for people who also build
strong relationships and can influence
and motivate others and i think that's
another just really fundamental piece i
mean all of our studies about
transformational teachers it's
interesting like the number one
differentiator is that they're
incredibly relational not even just with
kids but with anyone like the other
teachers in the building and such so you
know there's a lot to
like trying to select those folks and
invest build putting them in a culture
and helping them understand and see like
different
models of teachers who are fostering
their students leadership and building
their skills and providing the ongoing
coaching and mentoring and
access to resources necessary to develop
over time
yeah it makes a ton of sense and i just
realized whenever i'm having a good
conversation the time goes far faster
than i expect so maybe we'll finish off
there's a question from cl grouse on
facebook uh being that we have been a
pandemic for almost two years are there
any changes within the organization that
weren't there prior to 2020. so if you
could take us home on what is a pandemic
done to teach for all
to teaching and any other takeaways you
want folks to have
yeah um
you know i think this in a way teach for
all's network was kind of made for this
era
i think it's just been really affirming
for the kind of teachers and leaders
we're developing who
as the world schools shut down
progressively just leaned in with their
own students to to keep them safe and
learning and then we're very quickly
enlisted by government ministries around
the world and others to train other
teachers in distance learning strategies
create digital libraries leverage radio
and tv to keep kids learning and so
we've just seen
so much leadership and so much
innovation across our network and we've
also seen the power of having a global
network that would enable all those
teachers and
alumni educators to learn from each
other i mean we just saw solutions
flying across the world um so so that's
that's maybe a part of the answer we've
been reflecting a lot on
what we're learning in this era
and of course we're seeing
the issues we're addressing like the
inequities we're addressing
just hugely exacerbated in this time but
we're also seeing a lot of new
possibilities like mindset shifts a lot
of them among the world's educators i
mean our networks educators and the
world's educators about the power of
leveraging technology the power of and
you know engaging students in shaping
the learning experience like partnering
with them to do that the power of
partnering all the more deeply with with
parents um the importance of integrating
a focus on well-being and social
emotional
development at every single step of the
way in every every day
and probably more but so we're really
thinking about how do we
how do we sustain those mindsets because
if we can do that
we really have the potential to have a
different and much better school system
as as we go forward
you know so it's so exciting and look
wendy i would say i could talk to you
for hours and i i will say you've always
been an inspiration the existence i
didn't know you when i started khan
academy we got to know each other quite
quickly uh i consider myself very
fortunate
but i
the the existence of teach for america
and teach for all is what gave me
confidence that you could have
innovative not-for-profits at scale that
can really make a dent at a national or
global level and obviously what we're
trying to do in are the various
not-for-profits we also have a habit of
starting more than one not-for-profit
then the various not-for-profits that
we're doing uh obviously i've started a
tutoring platform schoolhouse.world
in some ways it it rhymes with a lot of
what you're talking about about people
wanting to give back and i think what
we're doing is so complementary i i'm
super excited about where where
education can go with with your
entrepreneurship and these 70 000 folks
that you have joined your army uh thank
you for for doing that for the world
well thank you sal and your journey has
also been a huge source of inspiration
and support to our whole network and so
many leaders across our network and i
myself so
thank you for that we really value
our kind of informal partnership with
with khan academy
absolutely well thank you so much
well thanks everyone for joining
oh thanks so much wendy uh thanks
everyone for joining uh as you could
tell wendy is one of the real if you
think of a list of five people in the
last 30 years who you would list on
making a dent in the universe especially
a dent in the universe in education i
think wendy would would make that list
so uh thank you for joining as you can
see she's incredibly inspiring and her
journey is incredibly inspiring so thank
you for joining the homeroom and i will
see you all at the next one which is
still going to be in a little while but
see y'all then
you